The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies
and gentlemen,
welcome to lecture four.
In the last lecture, I presented
to you a general
formulation for finite
element analysis.
In this lecture, I would like
to talk to you about the
derivation of specific finite
element matrices.
The formulation that we will be
using, or the derivation I
should say, that we will be
using, leads us to generalized
finite element models.
I will be talking later on
about what we mean by
generalized.
Let's remember, let's recall
what we arrived
at in the last lecture.
We had that the element
stiffness matrix for element m
is obtained by this integration
here where we
integrate the product of a
strain-displacement matrix
times a stress-strain matrix
times the strain-displacement
matrix over the volume
of the element.
We also had derived the
expression for a body force
vector, B. m, again,
denoting element m.
And here, we integrated over the
volume of the element the
product of the displacement
interpolation matrix times the
body forces in the element.
We also had derived a surface
force vector of the element in
which we integrate the product
of the surface interpolation
matrix times the surface forces
applied to the element.
So in essence, we see then if we
look at these expressions,
we see that we need really a B
matrix, a strain-displacement
matrix for the element.
Of course, we need the
stress-strain law for the element.
And that will really be given to
us from the serial strength
of materials.
We also want the displacement
interpolation
matrix for the element.
Once we have this displacement
interpolation matrix, we can
directly obtain the
interpolation matrix for the
surface displacement of the
element by simply substituting
into this matrix here, the
surface coordinates.
In summary then, we need the H
matrix, the B matrix, and the
stress-strain law for every
element that we have in the
assemblage.
Notice that the stress-strain
law, of course, must depend on
what kind of element
we are looking at.
How we have mechanically
idealized our system.
In a truss structure, we will
have simply the Young's
modulus in here.
In a plane stress idealization,
we will have a
plane stress law.
In a plate bending idealization,
we will have the
plate bending stress-strain
law in there, and so on.
Well, I want to talk today
about these matrices.
How do we obtain
these matrices?
Once we have talked about that
subject, I finally want to
also spend a little bit of
time talking about the
convergence of the
analysis results.
Of course, in finite element
analysis, we must be concerned
about the accuracy of the
analysis results that we are
obtaining, and about the
convergence of the results to
the actual analytically,
theoretically accurate result
that we want to obtain.
Well, let us then first talk
about the derivation of the H,
B, and C matrices.
And the H, B, and C matrix,
of course, depend on the
particular problem that
you're looking at.
Let us therefore categorize
the different types of
problems that we encounter
in structural analysis.
Here we have a truss structure,
and a truss
structure is really an
assemblage of truss elements.
And in each truss element that
lies between the nodes, we
have one-dimensional
stress conditions.
In other words, the only stress
that we see on the
section AA would be
the tau xx stress.
And that is the only stress, no
other stress is involved.
Of course, just going a little
bit ahead, we immediately
would also say that the only
strain we would be interested
in is epsilon xx and the
stress-strain law is simply
Young's modulus.
The second kind of analysis that
we might be performing is
a plane stress analysis.
In plane stress conditions,
the only stresses that are
non-zero are tau xx,
tau yy, and tau xy.
Remember in lectures three, I
had listed all six stress and
strain components.
And what I'm doing now is I take
out just those stress and
strain components that are
really applicable for the kind
of problem that I
want to look at.
Plane stress situations we will
encounter in the analysis
of a beam, for example.
Here's a simple cantilever
beam subjected to
surface loading p.
And if we look at an element
here, it is redrawn here.
We would find that
tau xx would be a
stress into this direction.
Tau xy is the shear
stress, and tau yy
is that normal stress.
The cantilever, of course, can
be subjected to a surface
loading, a bending moment, tip
loading, whatever loading.
The stress components, the only
stress components that we
assume of course, act in the
structure would be these three
stress components.
In fact, of course, in the
actual physical situation, we
would find that around here,
depending on the specific
support conditions that we are
using, we would have a much
more complicated stress
situation than the plane
stress situation assumed.
However, if we are only
interested in the tip
displacement here, or the
displacements away from the
support condition from
the support.
Similarly, if we are only
interested in the stresses and
strains away from the support,
certainly it is accurate
enough to--
it yields an accurate enough
model to assume a
plane stress situation.
Another plane stress situation
occurs here, for example,
where we have a sheet
with a hole.
If the sheet is thin, the only
stresses that we would see on
an element, such as shown here,
would be z stresses, the
plane stress stresses.
A next category of analysis
that we would encounter in
practice is a plane
strain condition.
Plane strain condition means
that in the space xyz shown
here with the displacements uvw,
the displacement w is 0.
It's identically 0 if our x,
y-coordinate system lies in
the plane of a typical section
of the total problem.
And let me show you
one such typical--
or describe to you one such
difficult problem.
Here we have a dam that
is very long.
In fact, we might assume
it infinitely long.
And it is supported on this
face here, so that w, the
displacement, normal
to that face is 0.
And the same support
conditions are
at the other face.
If the dam is subject to uniform
water loading, water
pressure loading all along its
side, then by symmetry it
follows that w, the
displacement, at any section
of the dam, the displacement
normal to that
section must be 0.
Therefore, we have w 0 meaning
directly epsilon zz 0.
The strain into the z-direction
is also 0.
Similarly, the shear stresses,
tau zx and tau zy are 0.
And the only stresses that we
are left with which are
non-zero are those shown here.
These are the stresses acting on
a typical slice of the dam.
A slice say, of unit length
would be subjected to just
these stress conditions.
Therefore, in that array of six
stresses and strains that
I talked to you about in lecture
three, we really only
are concerned--
you only need to calculate these
four components of those
six that I talked about there.
Another stress-strain condition
that we are
interested in frequently in
practice is an axisymmetric
analysis condition.
This case we have an axis of
revolution for the structure,
and here we look at a
cylinder, which is
axisymmetric in geometry about
that center line here, the
axis of revolution.
And the loading is also assumed
in this particular
case to be also axisymmetric.
So typically, we are talking
about a cylinder, circular, of
course, when looking from a
plane view subjected to
internal pressure, which
is the same all around.
And of course, the geometry is
also axisymmetric when we look
at the axis of revolution, the
center line of the cylinder.
In this particular case, the
only stress conditions that we
need to calculate are
shown here for an
element in that cylinder.
We have tau xx, tau
yy, tau zz.
This, of course, being
the hoop stress.
And the shear stress, tau xy.
These are the stress conditions
that we need to
calculate for this
particular case.
Similarity, because we are
talking about an axisymmetric
condition, an axisymmetric
condition where really, every
one of these elements behaves
in the same way, we can look
at one radian of the total
circumference in the analysis.
So this is an axisymmetric
analysis, which we also are
concerned with frequently
in practice.
Finally, the very large
number of analyses--
in a very large number of
analyses, we consider plates
and shells.
If we look at a plate, an
element in that plate, we
would find that in general we
would have the tau xx, tau yy.
These are the normal stresses.
And tau xy shearing stresses
in the plane of the plate.
We would also have transfer
shearing stresses,
tau xz and tau yz.
Sorry, tau yz, shown
here as the
transfer shearing stresses.
Of course, these transfers
shearing stresses give us
shear forces.
And these stresses here give
us membrane forces plus
bending moments and
twisting moments.
Elementary theory of plates
shows us, tells us, that these
are the significant stresses
in a plate.
The important point is that in
a plate, as well as in a
shell, the stress normal
to the plate is 0.
The same holds for the shell.
The stress normal to the shell
is 0, and we have the stress
components.
However, we have to now remember
that the xx and yy
axes are aligned with the
curvature of the shelf.
Are aligned with the curvature
of the shell.
And then these are the stress
components that are of
interest in the analysis
of shells.
In many cases, when we look at
the analysis of plates, the
membrane forces--
the total membrane
forces are 0.
In which case, of course, we
assume that tau yy has a
linear variation through the
thickness of the plate.
As stipulated, for example, in
the Kirchhoff plate theory.
This much then for the static
components, or rather the
stress components of plates and
shells when we look at the
kinematics of plates
and shells.
Just to remind you, we assume
that there's a normal to the
mid-surface.
And that normal in Kirchhoff
plate theory remains during
deformation normal to
the plate surface.
And all material particles on
that normal AB remain on a
straight line.
These are the two things.
I repeat, all material particles
on the line AB
remain during deformation on the
line AB, and the line AB
remains normal to the
mid-surface in Kirchhoff plate
theory, which does not exclude
shear deformations.
However, if we use a theory
that does include shear
deformations, we would still
have that the material
particles on line AB will still
lie after deformations
on the line A prime
B prime say.
But the line A prime B prime--
B is still a straight line-- is
not anymore normal to the
mid-surface.
In this case, we have included
shear deformations.
We will see in the next lecture
that, in fact, it is
simpler to use a theory
including shear deformations
to derive effective
finite elements.
Well, this then is a review
for the kinds of stress
components and strain components
that we are
interested in.
Of course, that information
which I discussed so far is
available from the strengths
of material theory and
continue mechanic theory.
And as an engineer, however, we
have to be able to decide
what kind of stress and strain
situations you want to analyze.
And there, of course, is already
one very important
assumption.
A very important assumption in
laying out or starting with
the right model for the actual
physical structure.
Whether we want to model the
actual physical structure as a
truss assemblage, as an
assemblage of plates, beams,
et cetera, all of those
situations can be covered in
the finite element theory.
But we have to make the right
assumptions right from the
start in starting with
the right model.
So here I listed ones.
In one table, the particular
problems
that we might encounter.
We might have a bar.
The displacement components
then being simply u.
In a beam, which I have not
given earlier, but here we
have a transverse
displacement, w.
In plane stress situations, we
have two displacements, u and
v.
In a plane strain situation,
u and v.
In an axisymmetric situation,
Three-dimensional situation,
we have u, v, and w.
In plate bending, simply the
transverse displacements.
In analysis of shells, in the
analysis of shells we would,
of course, have the transverse
placements and also the
membrane displacements
included.
We will talk about that
in the next lecture.
These are the displacement
components for the particular
problem that we are
looking at.
And correspondingly, we have
particular strains.
The strains that we are talking
about are in the bar,
simply the normals strains.
In a beam, the second derivative
of the transverse
displacements.
Here we have kappa xx defined.
This is kappa xx defined.
In plane stress, we have
these three components.
Plane strain, these
three components.
Axisymmetric these three
components, and so on.
And it is here, of course,
where the engineer has to
decide what kind of problem he
has in hand when he actually--
when he looks at an actual
physical situation.
Corresponding to these strains,
we have also stresses.
And here we are listing
the stresses.
Notice that for the beam, we
are talking about a bending
moment, which we might
consider to be
a generalized stress.
In plate bending, we talk
similarly about bending
moments, which you also
might consider as
being generalized stresses.
Otherwise, we have the actual
stresses that correspond to
the strains.
Having decided what stresses
and strains we
want to look at--
in other words, what kind of
problem we have at hand, we
also have to select the
appropriate material matrix.
Again, this one is given form
strengths of material.
Here, for a bar, a truss
structure, we simply have
Young's modulus.
For a beam, we have the
flexural rigidity.
In plane stress analysis, this
would be the material law that
you would find in many
textbooks on
strengths of materials.
Well, having therefore resolved
the problem of how to
establish the stress-strain
law, or the stress-strain
matrix c, we now go on to
discuss the construction of
the displacement interpolation
matrix.
For a one-dimensional
bar element,
we would have simply--
we can assume simply a
polynomial with unknown
coefficients, alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3.
And this is simply
a polynomial nx.
x being, of course, the
coordinate that is being used
to describe the displacement
for the element.
For two-dimensional elements,
here we're talking about plane
stress, plane strain.
Axisymmetric analysis, we would
have, similarly, these
assumptions here.
alphas for the u displacements
and betas for the v
displacements.
For the plate bending element
in which we only discretize
the w displacement, the
transverse displacement, we
would have this assumption
here.
For three-dimensional solid
elements, similarly, we have
these assumptions.
Notice that these gammas,
alphas, betas are unknowns for
the element.
And we will actually relate
these coefficients to the
nodal point displacements
of an element.
If we look, therefore, in
general, at the description of
an element, we really have on
the left-hand side here, the
actual displacements, the
continuous displacements in
the element being given by
matrix phi, which contains the
constant and x, x squared,
x cubed terms, and so on.
And this alpha vector here
contains the generalized
coordinates, the alphas,
betas, gammas.
Typically, therefore, just to
focus our attention on a
particular case, we might have
if we say that u of x for a
truss structure is equal to
alpha 0 plus alpha 1x plus
alpha 2x squared.
In this particular case, we
would have that we can write
this, of course, as 1 x x
squared in matrix form times
alpha 0 alpha 1, alpha 2.
And here, I'm talking about this
being equal to the phi,
and this being equal to
the vector alpha.
So just to give you an example
for this particular case.
If we now want to evaluate
the alpha values.
Of course, in two-dimension
analysis as I shown earlier to
you, we have also betas here.
In three-dimensional analysis,
we also would have gammas in
this vector.
If you want to evaluate these
alpha values, then we can
simply use this relation here,
or that relation here, and
apply it to the element
nodal points.
To the displacements at the
nodal points of the elements.
If we do that, in other words,
we substitute into here, into
the phi matrix, the actual
coordinate of the nodal
points, and on the left-hand
side, of course, the
displacement at that nodal
point, we directly generate
this relation.
We can then invert this relation
to obtain alpha.
And here, we have now the
generalized coordinates in
terms of the nodal point
displacements.
This then would really complete
the evaluation of the
continuous displacements u in
terms of the nodal points
displacement u hat.
If we have laid down this
assumption, we can directly
also obtain the relation for the
strains of the elements.
We have decided what kinds of
strains we want to look at
that we have to include.
And by proper differentiation of
the rows here, we directly
generate this relation.
Of course, this is a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
relation then for the material
of the element.
And we then directly have
tau in terms of alpha.
But alpha was already given
in terms of u hat here.
In summary, therefore, we have
our displacement interpolation
matrix here, given as
phi times a inverse.
This is obtained by simply
substituting from here,
substitute from here,
directly into there.
And you get that u is
equal to H u hat.
And our H being phi a inverse.
Once again, the u is the
continuous displacement in the
elements. u hat has nodal point
displacements in the elements.
Similarly, if we substitute
from here into there and
recognize that our epsilon
strain is equal to B times u
hat, we directly obtain
that B must be equal
to E times A inverse.
Well, let us now look at a
particular case, a particular
example to demonstrate how we
proceed for a particular case.
Here I'm looking at the analysis
of a cantilever
subjected to a load.
And I've idealized that
cantilever as an assemblage of
four elements.
Each element is a four
nodal element.
So for element 1, we have nodes
1, 2, 4, and 5 of the
global assemblage.
Notice that all together
we have 9 nodes.
And once again, 4 elements.
The cantilever structure is SiN
and we believe that it is
appropriately modeled using
a plane stress analysis.
In which case, the only stresses
that are of concern
are the stresses in this
plane, tau yy,
tau xx, and tau xy.
So these other stress components
here are 0.
If we look now at a particular
element to focus our attention
on one element, because
all these elements
are really the same.
Basically, the same.
Let's look at element 2.
And we notice that element 2
being a four nodal element is
shown once more here with the
displacements U1, V1 at the
local nodal point of
the element 1.
V2, U2 being the displacements
of the local nodal point 2.
And here, V3, U3 similarly
for nodal point 3.
And V4, U4 for nodal point 4.
We have taken this element of
the assemblage and what we
want to really do is derive the
displacement and strain
interpolation matrices for this
element corresponding to
U1, V1; U2, V2; U3,
V3; and U4, V4.
If we have done that, we
recognize, of course, that U1
corresponds to a global
displacement.
Similarly, V1 corresponds
to a global placement.
Then we can directly construct
the displacement and strain
interpolations corresponding to
the global displacements.
But the finite element procedure
is really to look
locally at an element.
Locally at an element.
And work in terms of local
displacements.
Later on then, we relate the
local displacements to the
global displacements.
The advantage of proceeding this
way is that we really--
in looking at one element,
we look at all four
simultaneously.
The procedure then is, once more
in summary, we want this
matrix here, the H2 matrix
corresponding to element 2.
The vector U lists all of the
displacements, all of the 18
displacements.
However, we will look at the
element 2 with local nodal
point displacements, forgetting
about the global
nodal point displacement.
And our objective is to derive
a relationship of u equals H
times u hat, where u hat
lists U1, V1; U2, V2;
U3, V3; U4 and V4.
Once we have this H, which is,
of course, a 2 by 8 matrix,
because there are 2
displacements, u and v. The u
and v displacement
for the element.
And there are 8 entries
in u hat.
Therefore, this H matrix
must be a 2 by 8.
Once we have obtained this H
matrix, we can construct
directly our H2 matrix that
we talked about earlier.
Well, let's proceed then in the
way that I discussed in
general form earlier.
Since we have a four nodal
element, let me just sketch it
once more here.
Since we have a four nodal
element, and we are talking
about u and v displacements, we
really can only have four
constants, four generalized
coordinates.
Generalized coordinates
corresponding to the u and
corresponding to the
v displacements.
Remember that the only unknown
u displacements are these 4.
And these 4 u displacements will
give us alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, and alpha 4.
The same holds for the
v displacements.
This is a bilinear approximation
of the u
displacements in the element.
We write this in matrix
form as shown here.
Noting that this capital Phi,
notice this is a capital Phi
because there are these
cross bars.
It's easy to confuse the capital
Phi with the lowercase
phi, which doesn't have
the cross bars.
So this capital Phi was
the cross bars here
is defined in here.
Where the lowercase phi
is simply an array
of 1, x, y, x, y.
This relationship here is
nothing else than that
relationship, but written
in matrix form.
The alpha lists all the
generalized coordinates.
The generalize coordinates.
And this is the reason why we
call this the generalized
coordinate finite element
formulation for this
particular element.
Let us now define the
u hat vector,
which I refer to earlier.
This case, the u hat vector
involves 4 u nodal point
displacements and 4 v nodal
point displacements.
Now if we apply--
and this is really one
important point.
If we apply this relationship
here, which of course must
hold all over the element.
In particular, it must also hold
for the nodal points of
the element.
If we apply this relationship
for the nodal points of the
elements, we can apply it eight
times because we have 8
nodal point displacements.
We directly generate this
relationship here.
u hat equals A times alpha,
where A involve the
coordinates of the
nodal points.
Hence, we have our H Phi times
A inverse the way I have
derived it earlier.
So this is a very systematic
approach of deriving the
displacement interpolation
matrix.
It consists of evaluating
the A matrix.
And of course, we assume that
that A matrix can be inverted.
This is, for this element,
certainly the case, as long as
we are talking about the
rectangular element or not
very highly distorted
elements.
We can for the four nodal
element, invert this matrix
and directly get this
relationship.
Let's look now, once more back
at the analysis that we wanted
to perform.
Remember that we looked at this
element here, and we have
now obtained the H matrix, the
displacement interpolation
matrix for this element.
Once more, here is
the H matrix.
In fact, this H matrix here,
since we have no superscript
attached to it yet, really holds
for every one of the 4
elements that we are
talking about.
Provided we put into the u hat
here the appropriate nodal
point displacements
of the elements.
We can directly say that this
matrix here holds for any one
of the elements.
If the elements, if the 4
elements are not completely
identical, of course, the A
inverse will change from
element to element.
Having gone through that step
and having looked at element 2
once more, we directly recognize
how to establish now
the H2 matrix.
Remember our u1 will be related
to the global U11.
Our v1 will be related
to the--
or will correspond I should
rather say, to the global U12.
Let's look at why this
is the case.
Why did I write down U11
here and U12 there?
Well, let's look at
this point there.
Which is of course, the
local nodal point 1.
The local nodal point 1, right
upperhand corner of element 1,
corresponds here to
nodal point 6.
Well, the global nodal point
displacements of
nodal point 6 are U11.
Let me put them in.
And U12.
Why is that the case?
Well, if we start numbering
here-- and I'm going to
include now, I'm going to
include now the displacement
of these nodal points, although
we know that they are
actually 0, that boundary
condition we can
impose later on.
So if I start numbering here, I
would have U1, U2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
So the global nodal point
displacements are U11, U12
corresponding to
nodal point 9.
And those are the ones that
appear right here
corresponding to the local
U1 and the local V1.
Well, if we proceed in the same
way for all of the other
nodal points for element 2,
and these are the results.
You can look these up in the
textbook figure 4.6, or in the
accompanying notes.
We can directly construct the
H2 matrix for the element.
And now the H2 matrix, of
course, involves as the vector
the global nodal point
displacements, U1 to U18.
The H matrix for element 2.
And if the 4 elements are
identical, we will have the
same H matrix for all
the elements.
The H matrix here looks
as shown here.
Notice that we have a
one quarter there.
It's a little arrow here.
The bracket should've
been there.
Bracket should have
So we have a one quarter
outside of the bracket.
And we have as the first
entry, this one here.
This corresponds to U1.
This is the entry corresponding
to U1.
I left the entries
corresponding
to U2, U3, U4 out.
This is the entry corresponding
to V1.
And I left out the entries
corresponding to V2, V3, V4.
This is our H matrix here.
And now we basically want to
blow it up to obtain the H2
matrix corresponding
to element 2.
Well, if we recognize as we just
did that U1, the local
U1, the local V1, correspond
to capital U11 and capital
U12, and I just showed you that
that is indeed the case.
We would simply take the first
element here, this element
here, and put it right there.
This element here would
go right there.
And this element here would
In fact, H1 5 is 0 as
you can see here.
And H2 1 is 0.
So H1 1 is this term here.
And H2 5 is that term here.
Those are two non-zero entries
in the complete H matrix.
Well, this is then the way how
we actually can proceed to
construct the H2 matrix.
I pointed out earlier in lecture
three already that we
do not perform this step
computationally.
In fact, what we do
computationally is we stay
with this H matrix.
We calculate a compacted
stiffness matrix, a compacted
load vector, which the stiffness
matrix will be of
order 8 by 8.
And then we assemble these
element matrices with
identification arrays and
connectivity arrays into the
global structural stiffness
matrix, into
the global load vectors.
So we really don't perform
this step of
blowing up the H matrix.
And I will show you in the next
lecture how we actually
perform the computations of
assembling element matrices.
However, for theoretical
purposes, it is neat if you
understand how we can construct
this H2 matrix from
this H matrix.
And of course, similarly, we
could construct H1, H3, and H4
from this basic H matrix.
Once we have done that, we can
directly write that k being
equal to the sum of the km.
In other words, the global
structure stiffness matrix is
equal to the sum of the element
matrices, stiffness
matrices, where each of these
km's has the same order as the
structure stiffness matrix k.
Let us now look briefly at the
development of the strain
displacement matrix.
In plane stress conditions,
we have three entries.
The strains are given
as shown here.
Elementary strengths materials
tells us that
these are the strains.
And I showed earlier that the
B matrix is constructed by
multiplying the E times
the A inverse.
The A inverse was already used
in the calculation of the
displacement interpolation
matrix.
The E matrix is obtained by
appropriately differentiating
the entries in the displacement
interpolations.
And this differentiation is
performed on the phi matrix
right here.
Or rather, on these
entries here.
By simply differentiating these
entries here, we would
obtain the strains and writing
those in matrix form, we
obtain the E matrix here.
Once we have the B matrix, which
in this particular case
is 3 by 8 matrix for a typical
element, we can, of course,
construct the B2 matrix for
element 2 just in the same way
as the H2 matrix.
Of course, we would again,
blow up the B
matrix from a 3 to 8.
3 by 8 I should rather say, to
a 3 by 18 now because we have
actually 18 degrees
of freedom in the
complete structural model.
This then completes what I
wanted to say about the
construction of the
displacement and
strain-displacement
interpolation matrix for the
element, the H2 and
B2 matrices.
However, let me just spend
a few moments on the
construction of the surface
displacement
interpolation matrix.
In other words, the
interpolation of the
displacements along the
surface of an element.
Here, assume for example, that
this is a surface of the
elements that we are
concerned with.
And that there would be some
loading applied to that
surface of the element.
So that we need, in other words,
the HSM matrix the way
I have been pointing
it out earlier.
What we would do to obtain this
matrix here, is really
simply use our earlier
results for the HS--
sorry, for the HM matrix.
And here we have the
H matrix and the H2
matrix for element 2.
What we would do is we would use
this matrix, or this one
of course, this matrix is
contained in this one.
And simply, substitute the
particular coordinates along
the surface.
Now, going back once more
to the element under
consideration.
If we are looking at this
surface, then y is constant
and equal to this
distance here.
So knowing y, we would simply
substitute that value of y
into this function here, and
thus obtain the HS matrix.
So, in general, therefore the
HS matrix is simply obtained
from the H matrix, or the HS2
matrix here would simply be
obtained from the H2 matrix by
substituting the coordinates
along the line, or along
the surface that we are
considering.
Let us now to look at the
overall process of the finite
element solution.
Here I have summarized what we
all are concerned about.
Of course we have the actual
physical problem that we want
to analyze.
We have a geometric domain that
we have to discretize.
A material that has to be
represented, a loading and the
boundary conditions.
All of those have to
be represented.
In the mechanic idealization,
the idealization step that is
a very important step that I
referred to earlier, we would
idealize the kinematics as being
a truss, plane stress,
three-dimensional, Kirchhoff
plate, kinematics.
The material isotopic elastic,
the loading, and the boundary
conditions.
And this mechanical idealization
really gives us a
differential equation
or equilibrium for
one-dimensional stress
situation, a bar.
We will have an equation
such as this one.
In the finite element solution
then, we operate on this
equation basically.
We want to solve the governing
differential equation of the
mechanical idealization.
The errors that we are
therefore, concerned with are
discretization errors by the
use of the finite element
interpolations.
And then, a number
of other errors.
Numerical integration
in space.
If we use numerical integration,
there would be
other errors introduced.
In the evaluation of the
constitutive relations, again,
errors would be introduced.
The solution of the dynamic
equilibrium equations, by
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] time
integration, mode
superposition further errors
would be introduced.
If you solved the governing
equilibrium equations, ku
equals r, by iteration there
would be further errors
introduced.
And of course, finally there
are round-off errors on the
digital computer.
What I want to do now in
discussing convergence, I want
to say that all of these
errors are negligible.
In other words, we are basically
evaluating the
integrations in space exactly.
There is no round-off because we
have an infinite precision
machine, and so on.
So all the errors that we are
looking at now are the
discretization errors,
And if we look only at
the discretization
errors, we can say some--
make some very fundamental
remarks about the convergence
of the finite elements scheme.
I've summarized here on the
blackboard some of these very
important concepts.
When we talk about convergence,
let us assume
first now that we are having a
compatible element layout.
In other words, we're using a
And then, we know that we have
monotonic convergence to the
solution of the
problem-governing differential
equations provided the elements
that we are using
contain:
Firstly, all required
rigid body modes.
This means, for example, that
for in a plane stress
analysis, the element must be
able to undergo three rigid
body modes, two translations,
horizontally and vertically,
and a rigid body rotation.
And the element must be able
to represent the required
constant strain states.
In a plane stress analysis,
three constant strain states.
Pulling this way, pulling that
way, and the constant shear.
If these two conditions are
satisfied, we have monotonic
convergence in a compatible
element layout.
What do we mean by a compatible
element layout?
Well, here I have show a small
picture showing two elements,
a white and an orange element.
And these elements are
compatible because we have
three nodes along this line
for each of the elements.
So the white element
displacements basically vary
parabolically along this line,
and so do the orange element
displacements.
No gap can develop between
these two lines.
Here we have an incompatible
element layout.
Two nodes that describe only
a linear variation
for the white element.
But three nodes for the orange
element describing a parabolic
variation in displacement.
Therefore a gap can open up and
this is an incompatible
element layout.
Well, let us assume then that
we have a compatible element
layout fist of all.
Then, typically for an analysis
such as this one, a
simple cantilever subjected to
a tip load, the convergence
that we would observe would
be the following.
As we increase the number of
elements that idealize the
cantilever, the displacement
measured here would
monotonically approach from
below the exact displacement.
What do we mean by exact
displacement?
Notice I put it into quotes.
Well, the exact displacement
that I'm talking about here is
the tip displacements that we
would calculate from the
problem-governing differential
equation.
Of course, that
problem-governing differential
equation also corresponds to a
mechanical idealization of the
actual physical situation.
And depending on which
problem-governing differential
equation we choose, we would
have a different dashed line.
But assuming now that we have
made up our mind which one to
choose, which mechanical
idealization to choose, and we
are choosing a corresponding
finite element idealization,
this would be the convergence
that we would observe.
And it would be monotonically
from below.
In other words, our finite
element model,
actually is too stiff.
It is stiffer than the actual
physical structure.
Well, why I think we can
intuitively understand that
quite well if we just recognize
that we are
constraining the displacements
within each element to only be
able to basically, take patterns
on that are contained
in the element.
In other words, for the four
nodal element here, we really
have for the U displacements and
for the V displacements,
only 4 displacement
patterns each that
the element can undergo.
So we are constraining the
exact displacements to be
really, approximated by these
displacement patterns.
And that makes the actual finite
element model stiffer
than the actual physical
structure.
If we have an incompatible
layout, and I showed earlier
what we mean by that,
then, in addition,
every patch of elements--
by patch of elements we mean
small assemblage of elements--
must be able to represent the
constant strain states.
It's not just that each element
must be able to
represent the constant
strain state, but
each patch of elements.
Also, then if this holds true,
then we have convergence.
But non-monotonic convergence.
By non-monotonic convergence,
I mean the following.
We might get this result for
a certain set of elements.
And as we increase the number
of elements, we are
oscillating about the correct
result, the exact result in
quotes again, and finally
we converge.
This is non-monotonic
convergence because we can
have solutions lying on either
side of the exact result.
Well, let me now show to you
some of the facts that I just
talked about on this
view graph.
What do these mean?
Well, I said already that each
element in every case must be
able to represent the
rigid body modes.
Here for a plane stress analysis
of a cantilever beam
shown here, we have 3
rigid body modes.
And as I mentioned earlier
briefly already, the element
must be able to go over, go up
as a rigid body and rotate as
a rigid body.
Why is this the case?
Well, if we look at an analysis
of the cantilever
where we have not a tip load,
but a load say, at this end
here, we know that the bending
moment looks this way.
Hence, these elements over here
must be able to freely
rotate and displace.
In other words, we know that the
exact condition, the exact
physical condition, there should
be no stress here.
The stress should be
0 in this element.
And this means that the tip
element here must be able to
translate freely as
a rigid body and
rotate as a rigid body.
If this were not the
case, then we would
get stresses here.
And of course, our analysis or
finite element model can never
predict the actual physical
conditions accurately or
closely, even if we take an
infinite number of elements.
So this somehow explains to you
intuitively why the rigid
body more criteria must
be satisfied.
How about the constant strain
state criteria?
Well, if we assume that we take
more and more elements--
and let me draw in here
such elements.
For example, now we have gone
from a certain number of
elements to a larger
number of elements.
These elements, as we keep on
refining the mesh, would
become very small, and
would go down.
In fact, each element would
go down to a point.
But at a point we only have one
constant stress basically.
So the element must be able in
the limit, to represent the
constant stress at a point.
And therefore, we have the
constant stress criteria also.
One way of finding out whether
an element satisfies these
criteria, the constant stress
criteria and the rigid body
mode criteria is to calculate
its eigenvalues.
Here, we have taken ones.
A four node plane stress element
and calculate the
eigenvalues.
Notice the lowest three
eigenvalues are 0,
representing the rigid
body modes.
And then, we have a flexural
mode here, the fourth
eigenvalue.
The fifth eigenvalue is again
the flexural mode.
And here is the constant
sharing mode.
And here are the two
constant, one
compression and tension modes.
So these are the constant strain
states that the element
can represent therefore.
And earlier I showed you the
three rigid body modes.
So surely, this element
therefore satisfies both of
the criteria.
Let's look now at what happens
when we don't have a
compatible mesh.
We have an additional condition
that every patch of
elements must also be able
to represent the
constant strain states.
Only then we will have
convergence.
But we will not necessarily have
monotonic convergence.
We can only talk about
non-monotonic convergence.
Well, here I've taken
a patch of elements.
Each element by itself satisfies
the constant strain
criterion and the rigid
body more criterion.
In this case here, we use a
compatible element layout.
Compatible because along each
side, the adjacent elements
shares the nodes.
And we are subjecting this patch
of elements to a total
stress here of 100 Newton
per square centimeters.
Of course, the stress in each
of these elements would be
simply a stress this
direction of 1,000.
Excuse me, 1,000 not 100.
The other stress, the vertical
stress and the shear stress is
0 for this patch of elements.
Let us now perform the
following experiment.
Let us say that we are assigning
two nodes, two
different nodes to element
4 and 5 at this location.
Here they share the same node.
Let us do the same
at this end.
And let us say that node
17 only belongs to
this element 4.
Node 18 belongs only
to element 6.
Node 20 and 19 belong
to element 5.
In other words, node 17 can
basically gives this
displacement pattern.
And 19 gives this displacement
pattern.
An incompatibility
can reside here.
And similarly, along
this line.
If we subject this patch of
elements to the stress state
of the external forces that we
used here too, we would find
that the stresses at the points
A, B, C, D, E shown
along here, which here were,
of course, exactly equal to
1,000 for this stress tau yy
and 0 in this direction.
And the sheer stress was 0.
If you look at the tau yy
at A, B, C, D, E now the
incompatible element mesh
layout, we would find the
following stress result.
Notice that the stresses
now are not 1,000.
In fact, they vary drastically
from 1,000.
359 instead of 1,000.
This means that this patch
of elements with the
incompatibility here, does not
represent exactly the constant
stress state that it should
represent because we are
subjecting it to a constant
stress state.
Therefore, this patch of element
does not satisfy the
requirement for convergence.
Not monotonic convergence and
not non-monotonic convergence.
It just should not be used in an
actual practical analysis.
This completes what I wanted to
say then in this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.